well as if the price is right isn't
already a national treasure can you
believe this year is the show's 50th
season they're pulling out all the stops
got a special prime time show tomorrow
night and wow joining me right now is
the host of the prices writers drew
carey hey drew thanks for taking the
time man
what's up everybody how you doing nice
to see you well of course i am mostly
sunny but that's not why we're here i
wanted to talk about the prime time
special uh i understand you're gonna
have some of the biggest winners some of
the memorable come on downs tell us what
else we're gonna have on the show
uh two hour extravaganza uh yeah you
know the show's only an hour so
it's gonna be an hour's worth of pricing
games but it but then in between all
that
we have these amazing clip packages
and uh
and you know i talked to a couple
special celebrity guests like chris
o'donnell's gonna be on the show we have
a couple another
really famous celebrity that was on the
show once
before they were famous and then became
very very famous afterwards and they
don't want me to say who it is they want
it to be a surprise but
just from that hint okay should be able
to look it up and figure out who it's
going to be but it's a it's
it's done with such love and care it's
just great to see all these
fantastic memories and stuff that you've
probably ever seen before too i
understand that there's a tribute to bob
barker as well
bob by bob who
yeah
yes
never heard of him
but what a guy in fact you know you
carry on his tradition of you know
spaying and neutering pets at the end of
the show i mean that's bob barker now
that's you
yeah i promised him i would do that i
knew i was going to do it when i first
got offered the show i said well i have
to keep doing that because it's such a
part of the show and a matter of fact
you know people always ask me you know
when i met bob i've i met bob
more times at
animal rights events
because i'm one of my best friends was
sam simon
and uh
sam simon has a
peta building named after him bob barker
has a peta building named after him and
so sam simon and bob barker were became
very close because of their support for
animals and i would get invited to these
things and i saw bob moore at those
things that i saw
anywhere else
you know and uh he was such a
he is such a sweet guy
and really walks the walk when it comes
to all that uh
he's like an amazing spokesman for all
that stuff and very sincere and
authentic about it my favorite game and
i'm thinking it's a lot of people's
favorite game is plinko
but nobody wins money sometimes that's
the thing
they'll win like 10 grand or 12 grand
but we have
other games we're going 16 20
a car
you know
more than that people are you know these
crazy expensive trips and those are mike
if i was if i was on the show and i had
to play plinko i'd be like ah i'm only
going to win a couple grand i'd be
disappointed because i probably wouldn't
win that
much yeah the 50th anniversary special
is tomorrow night so it's an hour's
worth of stuff with a bunch of special
stuff right drew
yeah there's a regular prices right show
with jack really expensive jacked up
prizes and in between a lot of clips
awesome so that's tomorrow night at
night of course the daily show every
weekday morning at 10 right here on
channel 8 drew carey thanks for taking
the time knock on our door when you come
back to vegas vancouver we'd love to see
you again
thank you take care man bye
and he has been in vegas many many times
he happens to be a fan of the lon
bronson band that played for years at
the lounge at the riviera he liked him
so much he hired that band to play at
his end of season wrap party for his
cast and crew for the drew k show yeah
oh no for price is right over price is
right all right wow and you bumped into
him there didn't you absolutely so
i happen to know lon bronson because
he played at the riv where my wife was
in the show splash at the rip on
saturday nights at two o'clock in the
morning bronson bed would kick off for a
couple of hours and there was drew carey
hanging out one night
so cool but the big story of course is
price is right congratulations on 50
seasons for tpir
that's very cool good prizes too come on
down yeah well maybe they'll put a
million dollars on the plinko i was
going to say a special okay right
a little bit i love plinko but i hadn't
thought about how much
you don't might win on that versus a car
and it depends on how many uh plinko
play things you have tokens you have
tokens that's true well good luck to
everybody
he is nice super nice hey